je vous connais tu es moi je trouve
barman ce qui ce n'est pas parce que
l'on trouve que l'on connaît monsieur
c'est connu et vous regarder la télé en
travaillant c'est lors de mes cours
particuliers en dessous vous apprenez
quoi nous remet sur les palaces ont ce
ne sont pas les noms puis quand monsieur
c'est le rituel
- bruno quand tu vois la méditerranée la
turquie est pas d'avoir passé les
vacances de ton enfance au cap gris-nez
nous nous moi je suis du nord et fier de
l'être et dont c'était la mère était
moins bleu mais savait son charme les
grandes falaises on voyait envoyer
l'angleterre quand il faisait beau
serait arrivé de temps en temps et après
la costa brava sata pas plus et tout où
j'avais dix ans de plus donc j'étais un
petit peu moins sage
c'était quelques cousins cousines c'est
toute chose hein tu veux m'en parler à
limbé j'espère bien c'est même dire par
exemple son premier amour de vacances
c'était quand c'était en 68 mais c'était
pas vraiment pendant les vacances
il était juste avant juste avant les
vacances je vends ta première expérience
sexuelle ça recommence allait bien
alors bruno et qu'on est tous les deux
là qui a que nous y a plus que nous la
mère et la mère il va me parler d amour
de vacances alors oui c'était comment
j'ai pas de souvenirs plus plus fort que
pendant le lennon vacances unis est
arrivé de faire des galipettes sur des
plages de me faire surprendre par les
les flics ou les gendarmes
mais bon on est un peu sous toutes les
latitudes mais je suis pas programmé
pour faire l'amour que tu peux seulement
du 10 août que c'est pas plus l'amour en
vacances que pendant l'année toi non
plus tôt - ah bon ce qui va changer
c'est fait pour se reposer même de sa
vie moi tu as dit j'ai été puceau très
tard c'est à dire ça veut dire quoi ça
le vrai rapport sexuel je suis pas vert
22 ans non mais qu'est ce que j'ai
appelé depuis mai à 16 heures
des gentillesses mais c'était à l'époque
faut se rappeler que y'avait pas
vraiment la contraception
moi je me souviens la première fille
avec qui j'ai fait l'amour c'est j'étais
enfin qui est passé mon temps pour m'en
dtp à calculer si on s'était pas gouré
dnat
donc c'était
c'était moins évident quoi c'était
l'époque de la méthode ogino peu
compliqué ouais alors dix mois après tu
as fait beaucoup de voyages apprécier
ses vacances au cap gris nez c'est ses
vacances sur la costa brava ça fait
beaucoup de voyages et quels sont les
endroits qui ont le plus marqués quelles
sont les cartes postales que tu tues
garde en mémoire
bon ma femme travaille dans une
compagnie aérienne donc c'est du théâtre
qu'elle fait maintenant elle elle
travaille france d'une elle est tombée
bien bas
un travail dans une société de
production de télévision là là qu'elle
fasse attention et donc c'était parce
qu'un gagne parce qu'on regarde et la
mappemonde en se disant on pouvait
vraiment aller partout en plus on avait
des billets d'avion à 10% donc ce
n'était pas vraiment un problème
et finalement après avoir hésité pendant
trois semaines entre los angeles tahiti
et bora bora on aller dans l'autre en
train oui hier ça me coûtait plus cher
entre le billet d'avion pour aller du
moins
alors justement tes vacances aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que tu fais maintenant que tu
as épuisé toutes les voies de droit y
puiser mais c'est vrai que pour avoir
beaucoup beaucoup bourlingué je regrette
pas et c'est génial vraiment sans
chauvinisme je trouve la france et les
français s'en rendent pas assez couvrez
le plus beau pays où tout à fait claire
donc je moi j'aime bien aller en france
j'aime bien les dents de ce qu'on
appelle la france profonde
le massif central parce que c'est
vraiment authentique ya pas trop de
touriste et ça ils ont en fait je
squatte chez des copains ouais et et ont
bu vraiment on bulle on est bien entre
nous bookeen on déconne on qui colle on
va au restaurant
c'est une histoire c'est chez des
copains qui squattent dans le lot là
c'est ça se passe comment alors une
journée là bas serait justement c'est ça
qu'ils font mais on s'ennuie pas une
minute mais ya pas de piscine c'est
vraiment une maison tout aille à la
piscine une espèce de piscines en plein
soleil d'argonne pour tromper les fesses
parce que quelquefois il fait chaud mais
non bookeen on est vraiment bien chacun
vit sa vie
c'est bien parce que justement il se
passe rien ça fait des années qu'on se
voyait jamais on s'est engueulés jamais
car tu fais rien rien rien ou bulles
beaucoup mais en plus comme on connaît
un peu le point parce qu'on a bien sonné
on n'a même plus la curiosité d'aller
vers les sites touristiques en plus il
ya du monde dans une écoute donc on
reste chez nous tranquilles ou alors on
va aller on va voir les voisins enfin
c'est vraiment une vie de village
tu crois que c'est un art de savoir rien
faire comme ça oui c'est difficile en
plus je ne sais pour l'expérimenté
points
j'ai beaucoup travaillé la question et
c'est vrai que brûler
c'est qu abu les bulles et c'est
justement de n'avoir aucune obligation
dira rien sur son agenda aucun
rendez-vous qu'un coup de fil à passer
et puis pouvoir se dire je me fais cap
cinéma de suis je reste au lit tout seul
ou accompagné toute la journée je vais
faire du sport je fais mon jardin enfin
c'est de n'avoir aucun plan de travail
là tu es un spécialiste moi j'aime bien
mais c'est vrai alors loisirs jeter dans
la mer de tout laisser bien que là pour
quelques fois ça dérape s'apprête à des
occupations sont tus écrit un bouquin en
ce moment c'est sur soi sur le mensonge
ah bon alors je souffre beaucoup parce
que avant de laisser libre cours à mon
délire donc je mets crêtets en écrivant
là c'est plus contraignant comme
écriture
donc ces deux
moins jouissif mais parce que c'est un
truc construit et que je veux pas
sérieux je suis incapable de faire un
bouquin ça reste pour moi je crois que
non mais je crois qu'on peut dire des
choses extrêmement importantes grave en
déconnant croyons que
me c'est un vrai boulot est ce qui
t'arrive de dire des mensonges quand il
présente le journal
on va oui pas volontairement non mais
c'est vrai que quand on annonce la mort
de quelqu'un même si c'est quelqu'un
pour qui on n'a pas de l'indifférence ou
même de l'hostilité on va pas annoncer
avec un grand sourire donc il ya une
part de comédie
forcément on prend une tête
d'enterrement quand on annonce le décès
de quelqu'un même si c'est un mec mais
j'arrive bien pour qui on n'a aucune
estime il était arrivé d'annoncer des
fausses nouvelles toi sur le wii / petit
mission rage sur la roumanie j'étais de
services donc j'ai déconné autant que
les autres et mais même dans journal bon
je soutiens donc sur la marée noire qui
était un petit aspect de la guerre
on a tous dit on a tous dit comme en
écho en disant que c'était la marée
noire du siècle d'or qui s'est avéré un
an après que ces mails n'ont pas pas
grand chose et quand les journalistes
interviewé ce qui t'arrive de dire des
mensonges
non c'est pas des mensonges c'est des
mensonges par omission sur quai des
choses moi je suis le porte parole d'une
réaction donc il ya des choses que je ne
peux pas dire oui je ne peux pas dire
sur ma vie privée
qu'est ce tu vas faire là ce soir après
l'émission je te poses des questions
relatives à sortir sortir nombre à guy
peut-être à il sort pas beaucoup dans
les boîtes son gérant de ça parce que
j'aime pas le bruit et point d'oreille
donc ses beats et puis j'aime jour dans
la fumée donc je vis pas bien mais en
ayant pour les bois non pas d'une étude
ragoût alors vers le bord peut-être au
bar de la place à repérer déjà un peu
non les corrections de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus